[Musique]
vous êtes sur france 24
et vous avez raison bienvenue dans votre
journal de l'afrique à la une ce soir
l'élimination de l'algérie de la can
2021 les champions d'afrique en titre
ont été battus par la côte d'ivoire 3
busin à douala les éléphants finissent à
la tête de leur groupe avec la guinée
équatoriale aussi qualifié et dans le
groupe fc le mali gambie qui sont
qualifiés ainsi que la tunisie malgré sa
défaite explications à suivre on connaît
déjà certaines affiches des huitièmes de
finale qui débute ce dimanche
les violences policières au congo
brazzaville trois jeunes torturent et en
plein jour deux d'entre eux en sont
morts la vidéo a fait le tour des
réseaux sociaux reportage auprès des
familles des victimes
et nous irons au sénégal où on vote ce
dimanche pour les municipales des
élections plusieurs fois reporté est le
premier scrutin depuis la réélection du
président macky sall en 2019 reportage à
suivre à dakar une capitale très disputé
que le camp présidentiel espère ravir à
l'opposition
on ouvre ce journal par nelly mination
surprise de l'algérie de la coupe
d'afrique des nations les fennecs tenant
du titre ont été battus par la côte
d'ivoire 3 buts à 1 ce jeudi à douala
pour le sélectionneur sélectionneur
djamel belmadi c'est un échec total on
n'écoute pas avoir peur de dire le le
mot c'est un échec total
jamais pu marquer
même les penaltys on a du mal à les
marquer
donc
non s'est pas montré à la hauteur de la
compétition tout simplement
retour sur le match où les fennecs n'ont
jamais pu retrouver leurs vertus
collectives et offensive face à une
redoutable équipe ivoirienne avec notre
envoyé spécial à douala benoît paire au
chai c'est donc fini pour l'algérie le
tenant du titre et qui sort par la toute
petite porte de cette édition le bilan
il est maigre il est triste pour les
hommes de djamel belmadi un match nul 2
défaites un seul but marqué des fennecs
hors sujet ce soir qui pourront
difficilement se trouver des excuses une
équipe coupée en deux sans idée
totalement désorganisé en première
période face à des ivoiriens qui ont
appliqué à la lettre leur schéma
tactique beaucoup plus de maîtrise avec
un jeu plus rapide en une touche de
balle en déviation des ivoiriens
impressionnants de réalisme qui ont
marqué à deux reprises on peut en
première période caissier et ce hangar
et pour donner donc un avantage de deux
buts à la côte d'ivoire un handicap
quasiment insurmontable pour les hommes
de ben elle m'a dit qu'ils étaient
condamnés à la victoire ce soir à la
reprise la côte d'ivoire qui va encore
aggraver le score grâce à nicolas pp
très en vue ce soir le joueur d'arsenal
et comme un symbole de cette can ratée
de cette incroyable manque de réussite
des algériens dans cette 33e édition
riyad mahrez le joueur de manchester
city qui a raté un penalty
son tir qui a atterri sur le poteau
avant la paire la pause c'était bennacer
qui avait lui aussi trouvé le montant du
but ivoirien l'algérie qui va tout de
même sauvé son honneur grâce à sofiane
ben des pcaa score final 3-1 mais
l'histoire elle se répète pour l'algérie
souvenez-vous de la can 1992 organisée
au sénégal l'algérie était arrivé tenant
du titre et là aussi elle avait été
éliminée dès la phase de groupes
des ivoiriens qui eux affronteront et
bien l'égypte en huitièmes de finale des
pharaons qui ont eux aussi lutter pour
se qualifier en huitièmes de finale
l'autre équipe qualifiée dans ce groupe
e c'est la guinée équatoriale qu'il l'a
emporté 1 0 face à la sierra leone on
s'est entretenu plus tôt avec fayçal
métaoui journalistes à alger qui nous
raconte la déception des supporters
algériens suite à cette défaite et
l'élimination des fennecs dès le premier
tour
rappelant de très mauvais souvenirs
écoute
beaucoup d'espoir ce matin en pensant
que l'algérie pouvait surmonter la
défaite face à la guinée équatoriale
également le nil par sa équipe de
céréales yonne on pensait que l'algérie
allait gagner pour aller donc au
prochain tour et voilà que l'histoire se
répète puisque en 1992 l'équipe
algérienne à des détenteurs de titres de
la coupe de près qu'elle avait perdu été
éliminés du premier tour et s'était
également face à la côte d'ivoire à
l'époque la jedi perdu 3 aveyron
beaucoup de commentaires ce soit en
algérie beaucoup de déception beaucoup
de tristesse évidemment ans attendait on
attendait beaucoup de choses de
d'aider l'équipe deuxième est de ma vie
est belle ma diète et beaucoup beaucoup
de choses bonnes équipes algérienne et
là que la rachel coupe d'afrique la
coupe pour l'équipe prime à et ce soir
donc beaucoup de commentaires aussi sur
les choix tactiques de belmadi sur le
pourquoi il fait entrer tel jour telle
autre même bien sûr des commentaires de
supporters amer mais tout le monde pense
que maintenant il faut préparer la
prochaine phase puisque le temps 10 22
ça sera les tirages au sort pour les
matches barrages à la coupe du monde qui
va se rouler au pas paraît tellement de
monde dit aujourd'hui qu'il faut retenir
un peu cette leçon de l'échec au cameron
et préparer le l'équipe algérienne pour
ne pas pour la coupe d'afrique et
d'ailleurs il ya même déception a un ego
supérieur de l'état a nommé sans
surprise dans ce bois n'avait pas de
réel et beaucoup beaucoup de messages de
soutien bien que certains choix sportif
de belmadi sans critiquer l'équipe
algériens qui auraient pu faire mieux
selon des commentateurs à les autres
affiches de cette dernière journée de
qualification avant les huitièmes de
finale dans ce groupe f la gambie qui a
battu la tunisie mais qui est quand même
qualifié mali 2-0 face à la mauritanie
donc les qualifiés en tout une somme de
ce groupe sont les aigles du mali les
scorpions de gambie et voilà mais un
retour sur ce fameux match la gambie
avec notre envoyé spécial à libé cédric
ferreira
la gambie nouvelle équipe dans cette
coupe d'afrique des nations qui continue
de surprendre et cette fois elle et
gambien entre réalisé 1 rocourt en
battant l'un des favoris de la
compétition la tunisie ce match pourtant
au coup d'envoi et bien il n'y avait pas
vraiment d'enjeu puisque les deux
équipes étaient déjà qualifiées pour les
huitièmes de finale la préparation de ce
match à d'ailleurs été compliquée du
côté tunisien puisqu'il y avait encore
beaucoup de joueurs absents à cause du
coville 19 10 pour être précis le
sélectionneur de mondher kebaier qui ne
pouvait pas compter sur le leader
technique de son équipe wahbi khazri qui
avait d'ailleurs été fondamental dans la
victoire tunisienne contre la mauritanie
lors du match précédent et donc ce match
entre la tunisie la gambie a bien
démarré d'ailleurs pour les aigles de
carthage qui ont globalement dominé
cette première période et qui ont même
obtenu un penalty raté par seifeddine g
ziri sa frappe a été repoussée par le
gardien gambien baboucar guèye d'un
superbe arrêt en deuxième période les
deux équipes ont clairement baissé le
pied probablement pour garder un peu
d'énergie pour les huitièmes de finale
la tunisie a certes continué sa
domination mais ne s'est pas vraiment
montrer dangereuse et puis il ya eu
cette action en fin de match avec ce but
magnifique marqué par habib jallow son
deuxième but dans la compétition il a
envoyé une magnifique frappe en pleine
lucarne sa récompense c'est ce début de
compétition de la gambie qui continue de
surprendre et dont on se demande
maintenant où vont ils s'arrêter en tout
cas pour le moment ils sont qualifiés
pour les huitièmes de finale d'ailleurs
dans l'autre match qui s'est déroulé en
même temps le mali a battu la mauritanie
2 à 0 là aussi c'était un match sans
enjeu et musulmane était qualifié la
mauritanie éliminés on a donc premier de
ce groupe le mali 2e la gambie troisième
la tunisie
le programme de ces 8e de finale on
connaît pour le mali qui va affronter la
guinée équatoriale mercredi la gambie
elle va jouer contre la guinée
maintenant avant le début de ces
huitièmes de finale ça sera surtout aux
deux jours de repos pour toutes les
équipes avant la reprise de la
compétition dès dimanche avec un gabon
face au burkina faso et nous suivons
évidemment tous les résultats sur notre
site internet france 24 points communs
une explosion au ghana a fait plusieurs
morts et détruit près de 500 bâtiments
c'est un camion transportant les
explosifs qui est entré en collision
avec une moto on vient de l'apprendre et
le bilan n'est pas encore connu le
président a déploré sur twitter un
événement réellement triste malheureux
et tragique
on en vient à cette affaire de violences
policières au congo brazzaville début
janvier une vidéo fait le tour des
réseaux sociaux on y voit des policiers
qui torturent trois jeunes détenus en
plein jour et devant témoins deux
d'entre eux m'ont sont morts des suites
de ces sévices notre correspondante ausy
piotte est allé à la rencontre des
familles des victimes attention
certaines images peuvent choquer
cette vidéo qui a fait le tour des
réseaux sociaux montrent les traitements
infligés imbéciles gains et deux autres
détenus par des agents de police plaquée
sur le sol en plein air sous un viaduc
de brazzaville les jeunes hommes
reçoivent deux coups de marteau sur les
jambes seuls mes fils gars a survécu et
est aujourd'hui à l'hôpital
son nom que nous raconte cette soirée du
2 janvier la police a fait une incursion
dans leur maison en 2 heures et 3 heures
du matin ils ont pris mes trois neveux
ils ont emmené dans leur poste nous ne
savons pas jusqu'à lors le mobile de la
police et c'est le matin que nous
apprend que le pt abandonné à l'hôpital
de talangaï on a besoin la cheville en
novembre dernier six personnes avaient
déjà été retrouvées mortes au
commissariat de brazzaville une plainte
a été déposée pour ce militant des
droits humains la réponse doit être
politique face à ces qu'il décrit comme
des violences systématiques
ce qui est filmé vue mais ce qui n'est
pas filmé ce qui e
personne ne voit ce qui est fait dans
les endroits obscurs doit être encore
plus graves dont nous nous défendons
mais à la fin il faut que descendre au
delà des sanctions qu'il y ait une
vision politique bien claires et que
ceux qui ont la charge de ce genre de
situation sans rappeler à l'ordre démis
de leurs fonctions de son côté le
gouvernement déplore ces actes et promet
des mesures fortes pour servir d'exemple
nous sommes totalement désole de voir
circuler ce genre de vidéos et
d'apprendre que ses actes étaient commis
par des agents qui naturellement chargée
d'assurer leur public ce sont des actes
isolés de bandits policiers soit il il a
été traduit devant le procureur est
doublement que de grandes mesures déjà
prises à leur encontre la famille d'un
bécotte porter plainte contre les
auteurs des ces violences espère que
justice sera rendue à leur fils ainsi
aux deux autres jeunes disparus
on passe au sénégal où on vote ce
dimanche pour élire les maires et les
conseillers départementaux ce scrutin
plusieurs fois reporté est le premier
depuis la réélection de macky sall en
2019 c'est donc une répétition générale
avant la présidentielle 2024 et
certaines mairies sont particulièrement
discuté c'est le cas de ziguinchor en
casamance où le sud du pays où
l'opposant ousman sonko et candidats et
bien sûr de dakar la capitale qui est
l'un des derniers bastions de
l'opposition reportage de sarah sakho et
lehmann la
dernière ligne droite avant la fin de la
campagne abdullei dur sarba le rappel de
ses troupes au siège du parti au pouvoir
le ministre de la santé candidat de la
coalition présidentielle croit en la
victoire on a toutes les chances au soir
du 23 janvier 2022 de faire en sorte que
dakar soit gérée par un maire qui est de
bain au bord du lac à un mark est pas un
char des réalités
rn35 des dakaroise et de dakarois et
pour remporter la bataille de dakar aux
mains de l'opposition depuis des années
le candidat du pouvoir joue la proximité
comme ici aux parcelles assainies la
plus grande commune électorale de la
capitale abdoulaye diouf sarr promet une
politique plus inclusif des quartiers
plus sûrs ou encore une capitale plus
propre et les avec la jeunesse il a avec
2 au moment ils tous les humains vont se
voir à travers ce fonds a placé le
problème on n'a pas de battre les mines
on va gagner barthélémy dias l'autre
favori des municipales à dakar le
sulfureux opposant fait campagne aux
côtés de rallye face à l' l'ancien maire
déchu après une condamnation judiciaire
ce dernier éligibles la grande coalition
d'opposition mise tout sur bart comme
l'appellent les dakarois pour conserver
la capitale nous avons décidé dimanche
le 23 janvier 2022 de retrouver notre
dignité en votant pour partir les médias
c'est un moteur pour la croix les
chabbihas calvet qui incarne l'espoir et
l'avenir villes intelligentes espaces
verts propreté stationnement le
programme du candidat a aussi ses
adeptes barthélémy dias le mieux de ce
volume et pour la maire de dakar pour la
jeune tout un pays où les femmes de son
pays pour tous d'accord il est jeune
comme moi et que la jeunesse a besoin
dans un changement doudou wade le
candidat du pds le parti de l'ancien
président abdoulaye wade soit mail
wardini maire sortante et unique femme
candidate ou encore pape diop un autre
ancien maire de la ville au total cinq
autres personnalités sont sur la ligne
de départ pour cette course vers la
mairie de dakar l'un des enjeux majeurs
de ces municipales et c'est ainsi que
nous refermons ce journal de l'afrique
merci à tous ceux qui nous ont suivis
d'abidjan à alger en passant par female
à rester avec nous car l'actualité
continue sur 124
[Musique]
mettez-vous au rythme de l'afrique
la coupe d'afrique des nations du 9
janvier au 6 février sur france 24
[Musique]
pour ne plus laisser la buée sur vos
lunettes vous gâcher la vue regardez la
météo avec le kit anti buée sarris
efficace même avec un masque
[Musique]